Mike's in Philadelphia welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show Mike
and then what's up so a co-worker
introduced me to your show recently and
I really intrigued and I gotta say I
need a lot of help I'm 451 thousand
dollars and then total debt two hundred
and fifty two thousand of those student
loans and I have one hundred and eighty
five and a home loan and I only bring in
seventy thousand a year after pension
and all FF taken out it's more like
forty thousand I just don't even know
where to start
what do you do for a living the law
enforcement okay and how do you get two
hundred and fifty two thousand dollars
of student loan debt to be a policeman I
went to a private institution because my
mother wanted me to go there to be
honest with you I went there originally
for finance and I didn't do good at
finance so I switched my major to
criminal justice and then I eventually
went on for our masters for it as well
which didn't really help my employment
eligibility as much as I thought it
would mhm okay is your mother wealthy no
hmm no my mother and normal father I'm
the first in my family to go to college
okay well we always look at
mathematically and you were in finance
so you know what to do with this is I'm
always looking at the ratio of what we
call shovel to old the amount of hole
that you're in versus the shovel that
you have your income the debt you have
to your income are you married no I I do
have a girlfriend who lives with me and
her daughter as well mm-hmm and what is
this house worth that house is worth I
actually just purchased it and I even uh
you know I purchase in September kind of
a little whim my father
passed away in July and it was the last
conversation we had it was actually
across the street from his house and he
really wanted me to get it so I kind of
you know jumped in both feet I guess to
honor him you know and so you didn't put
anything down so the house was worth 185
yeah yeah and you're how old I'm 31 okay
so when do you plan on marrying this
girl
she's currently in school to finish up
for a nurse practitioner school so I
would say maybe sometime after that that
should be done hopefully after January
mm and does she have student loan debt
she does how much I'm not sure because
she's not really on board with all this
she can't I tried to bring this up to
her when listening to your show recently
and she's sort of thing as I'm too busy
with school and don't want to worry
about that right now
yeah well I think you're the voice of
experience that says it's a good idea to
worry about it otherwise you end up up a
creek which is where you are right now
and your paddle is real small okay well
let's look at this a couple ways how old
are you 28 I'm 31 31 okay you and I
haven't been friends long enough for me
to be as blunt as I'm about to be but
I'm gonna tell you anyway okay I'm gonna
risk our friendship and just tell you
the truth okay told me in a five-minute
conversation of two really stupid
financial decisions you made from the
influence of your mother and your father
you bought things you couldn't afford
with money you didn't have both because
of influence of those two at 31 years
old you were going to have to decide to
love your parents but no longer be
influenced to do financial decisions
based on their opinions obviously your
father's got
to Seoul this past but even your
perceived opinion of what he would have
thought you cannot please these people
anymore they are breaking your but you
make seventy thousand dollars a year and
you're so far in debt you can't breathe
dude
buying a house you can't afford and go
into a school you shouldn't have gone to
and paid twice or three times as much
for an education the most of which you
didn't even need to do the job unit you
do am I wrong right no okay no all right
and so number one that influence has to
stop number two you can't afford this
house as a single guy making seventy
thousand dollars a year you cannot
afford a hundred eighty five thousand
dollar house making seventy thousand
dollars a year as a single guy with to
my girlfriend's bring in about eighty
nine yeah well that doesn't count and
you're not married and if you're gonna
get married you guys are gonna have to
get on the same page financially because
the number one cause of divorce in North
America today's money fights and money
problems and she's not even willing to
talk about money so we're not willing to
talk about marriage until we're willing
to talk about money because you're gonna
get divorced as soon as you get married
that's what happens to most people it is
the number one cause of divorce how long
you been on the force for years okay
when you go on a domestic call what are
they fighting about money okay tell me
I'm wrong all right this is what's
happening and it's dangerous call for
you to because people are crazy Oh Lord
so yeah you guys have got to sit down
and go we can't keep this house unless
we're getting married and we're not
getting married unless we're not get on
the same page about the money and we
can't combine our incomes with people
we're not married to you can't go paying
her debt she can't go paying your debt
and this house it and hers it's yours
it's not in her name
it's in your name so either we let's
just go ahead and get married and
combine everything and attack these two
student loan debts and try to keep the
house or let's just call it a day and
get rid of the house and then you guys
figure out what you're going to do with
your relationship and stuff later go
rent something or whatever you
whatever you're doing before but but you
you know so several big issues I've
already hit on real hard number one we
can't afford a house number two you guys
you need to be real careful about
pursuing a long term relationship until
you get on the same page about money
number three unless you're married you
can't afford this house that I mentioned
you can't afford this house and then
lastly we got to do everything we can to
get your income up with side hustle side
gigs and you can get all kinds of OT in
the department right my department not
so much I don't have to actually go and
have to go outside of my department okay
they allowed you to do side work though
yeah yeah and that's good money right
now security is what forty fifty bucks
an hour right particularly yep private
security yeah and you need that money
cuz you're broke so income up out go
down get real focused and real narrowed
in your decision-making so that you can
clean this mess up because what you've
got in front of you that's 252,000 our
student loan debt with seventy thousand
dollar income is is a mathematical
nightmare so we got to get your income
up over 100 I'm gonna guess and say you
guys get married and we're probably
dealing with almost a two hundred
thousand dollar income at that point
when the two of you are going right and
but I'm also gonna guess she's got a big
butt Paula student loans too so I'm
probably dealing with four hundred
thousand dollars of student loan debt at
that point so probably you still can't
afford the house you're probably still
going to rent something cheap and you're
not gonna have any life for a while
because you both have made a big hole
that you're in and you can't get out of
a hole when you're digging at the bottom
so this is going to be very tough for
you Mike you got a lot of influences in
your life that have all brought bad
decisions so those influences have to
stop and then you've got to undo some of
these bad decisions or correct course
correct because five years from today if
you keep doing what you're doing
well Bobby you're but a slot Center and
five years from day you're gonna be
bankrupt you're heading straight at the
wall with the accelerator on
the floor that's what's happening right
now mathematically that's why you called
me I'm not picking on you I'm just
saying you have to turn the wheel you
have to turn the wheel and you have to
let the foot off the accelerator that's
all this is hold on I'm gonna put you
and the fiance through Financial Peace
University so that you guys can learn
how to handle money hopefully together
and hopefully we can salvage your
relationship